hi good morning
this is Andrew ID I'm president of Kent
Scientific Corporation I'd like to
discuss with you this morning a little
bit about small animal anesthesia the
and controlling the variables of your
experiments basically when a person is
doing studies over the years people of
neglected and neglected excuse me to
take in all the variables for and for
doing their experiment
lots of times if a person was doing a
neuro a neuro experiment they wouldn't
bother monitoring the heart rate or the
end tidal co2 or any of the other things
that would show that the animal was in a
normal physiological state or not so the
focus has become more on controlling all
of the variables so that your study can
be reproducible with other people and
keeping the animals in a very
physiological configuration so one of
the one of the things to take into
consideration is the type of anesthesia
when you're doing particularly when
you're doing animal surgery there's the
difference between injectable and
inhalation anesthesia and what some of
the problems that you have with the
injectable anesthesia compared to
inhalation is that are the are the
effects on the physiological parameters
of the animal just from the side effects
of the anesthesia so in our table here
we show a little bit of what
isoflurane does and compared to ketamine
and xylazine and and pentobarbital and
how they can affect your studies the
inhalation anesthesia is quite important
and it's really gaining in
popularity because of its ease of use
and fast recovery fast induction and
fast recovery of the animal and
basically being able to almost titrate
the level of anesthesia so there's two
sister two types of gas anesthesia
nowadays there's the traditional high
flow systems and they have they're
basically set up around the traditional
vaporizer
which is a big canister type thing that
usually weighs about 35 or 40 pounds
that's fed with oxygen or air the
traditional vaporizers have a bit of a
problem of being accurate in this and
this Acuras excuse me the accuracy of 10
isoflurane vaporizers and current
clinical use this is a snippet from an
abstract from this paper that was done
in 2011 this researcher looked at a
bunch of vaporizers in clinical use and
found that though the average was plus
and minus 20% overall the relative
deviation ranged from 62% from minus 62
percent to plus 21 percent in error of
the amount of anesthetic delivered and
the problem here is that he noticed that
there's a major problem with awareness
or overdose and even this was happening
despite the existence of in-house
calibration I think I think we've all
heard of stories of a person who's been
on the operating table and they've been
totally aware of the whole surgery that
they're undergoing but cannot commit but
they're paralyzed so they can't
communicate that
awareness to the anesthesiologist so
that can happen also in the animal range
or in animal settings the other problems
are that in in this snippet of an
abstract from the evaluation of ISO
fluorine and seal flooring vaporizers
over a wide range of of oxygen flow
rates this paper also found that the
accuracy was still plus and minus twenty
percent of the setting and and that was
over both high and low
low and high flow rates so just the
overall accuracy is plus and minus
twenty percent on average so we can see
the extremes and then here's just a
couple graphs from anesthesiology
websites that show that accuracy of
traditional vaporizers and these are two
models the tech two and the Ohio 100 are
models that a lot of the small chrome
vaporizers were built a built after so
you can see that typically in the tech -
which is a very common model in animal
research labs or the Ohio 100
particularly the tech - the at low flow
rates the it's all over the place and
the Ohio tends to have a low output at
low flow rates compared to balancing out
so the accuracy of traditional
vaporizers both from the studies and
from other sources here shows that it's
very very inaccurate that flow rates
below a half a liter per minute there
are several factors that influence the
output or vaporizer output which are
flow rate temperature and intermittent
back pressure on the flow rates
particularly this is taken from a
a PowerPoint presentation from an
anesthesiology professor and that the
link is on the bottom it shows that the
output of all variable past vaporizers
is less than the dial setting at low
flow rates it shows that insufficient
turbulence is generated in the
vaporizing chamber at low flow rates to
upwardly advance the vapor molecules the
also the temperature output is important
and you find that the the traditional
vaporizers weigh so much because they
have a big heat sink in them and if
there's a lot of vaporization going the
even that big massive copper heatsink
around the outside of the vaporizer
can't compensate for the change in
temperature on the inside and the change
in the vaporization and it's anecdotal
but I've been in several labs including
Jackson labs where the person the
researcher was using high flow rates
through a multi-channel vaporizer and
that that they over the course of an
eight-hour day and they start off at one
setting in the morning and bite and by
the end of the day their vaporizer is
almost at the maximum setting to get the
same induction capabilities of on in the
animals and lastly the intermittent back
pressure which can occur has a pumping
effect which can be caused either
increases or decreases in the amount of
isoflurane coming out so what makes a
good vaporizer this is a some some
slides taken from another professor
ideals for the ideal vaporizers it
should be simple safe satisfactory and
practice and more practical it should
have a low resistance to gas flow it
should it should be temperature
compensated for uniform vaporization
it should have flow stability and should
permit a relatively constant
concentration at different flow rates of
the carrier gas it should permit precise
accurate and controllable and
predictable deliverable concentration of
the vapor to the patient the form the
performance of the vaporizer should not
be affected by changes in gas flow
volume of liquid ambient temperature
pressure or anything else like that and
finally which should be lightweight
small liquid requirement construction
should be corrosive and solvent
resistant it should be of good quality
and the last one for the saamne suite
which will start discussing next it
doesn't really matter as far as the heat
sink also you'll notice that this is an
article that was or publication from AB
V and what they recommend for their non
rebreathing systems and the point here
is that they say never use less than 500
mm milliliters per minute due to
vaporizer requirements so even though
vaporizers many times are supposedly
certified for 200 MLS as the minimum
flow rate most laboratories have found
that that is unsatisfactory and that's
why even abbvie in their recommendations
for non rebreathing system says never
use less than 500 milliliters a minute
the recommended flow rates from
laboratory animal anesthesia third
edition by Paul a-flat nel recommends
that we use a two to two and a half
times the minute volume of the animal so
if we're just using allometric formulas
for a mouse 30 gram mouse the tidal
volume is 0.2 MLS respiration rates is
133 beats per minute this so the minute
volume is 20
six milliliters a minute so the carrier
flow gas should only be 50 to 65
milliliters a minute's is what's
required for a 30 gram Mouse which is
four times less than the minimum
requirement of some of traditional flow
and vaporizers and ten times less
essentially than the recommended amount
of the app-v paper or the Abdi
publication so this brings us to the
introduction of the low flow anesthesia
saamne suite produced by Kent Scientific
the saamne suite uses small volumes
shown here for a mouse with a two ml
glass syringe typically typically a 2 ml
glass syringe or 2 ml syringe will last
for to last 4 to 5 hours on a mouse in
an experiment so it's typically using
0.3 to 0.5 MLS per hour depending on the
depth of induction the other thing is
that the vaporizer is small the
vaporizer is electronic it's it's heated
by it's warmed electronically and it's
temperature controlled so we can dial in
a precise temperature which takes the
place of having to use a big copper
heatsink on the outside of the vaporizer
and then you can use those because it's
electronically controlled and feedback
temperature controls in Mon it will keep
the same temperature regardless if
you're using it for 15 minutes or for 15
days and let it run consistent
continually also the low flow anesthesia
has a very precision dial concentration
we can dial in concentrations of a tenth
of a percent instead of just kind of
guessing it at half percent with a
traditional vaporizer we can titrate the
anesthesia concentration to a tenth of a
percent
with Somnath sweet system the out of the
vaporizer comes the vaporizer block
comes in Satori line that goes to either
to a mask for the animal or if they're
doing spontaneously breathing if you're
doing spontaneously breathing animals or
if you're doing ventilating animals you
can install a ventilator module inside
of the psalmist weeks and actually have
the animal ventilated the excretory line
goes through the units and out to a
scavenging canister but typically
because we're only using particularly
for a mouse we're only using two MLS per
hour using a half ml per hour typically
for a full four or five hour experiments
you're using less anesthesia then
typically is built trying to fill a
funnel filled vaporizer so which is
really important because you're not that
falls under even OSHA guidelines for the
amount of anesthetic that's available
that's being used is being exposed to in
the room but anyway on the rear of it's
on the rear of the saamne suite we have
an outlet for the scavenging canister
there's also an inlet for compressed gas
such as oxygen if we're using oxygen its
compressed gas but the saamne suite also
has an internal pump which is used for
room air so you can switch back and
forth between them the typical
differences in the with the low-flow
saamne suite system are that a
traditional vaporizer and these are
readings taken at one liter a minute
because a lot of laboratories recommend
using vaporizers at 1 liter a minute the
traditional vaporizers compared to the
low-flow aspect of some the suite so you
have basically a thirty five to one
ratio between the amount of anesthetic
and the amount of
- flow in the amount of canisters that
would be used between the saamne suite
and the traditional vaporizer
here's another graphic showing that
between the Somnath suite and the
vaporizer so roughly for one but for
every bottle of isoflurane that you
would use in the saamne suite you would
use thirty-eight bottles in a
traditional vaporizer and the same thing
for the canisters same for every
canister you would use thirty-six over
every canister of the common suite you'd
use thirty-six in the regular
traditional vaporizer so what we have is
that we have either a traditional very
inaccurate vaporizing system for
delivering anesthesia or we have for
controlling the variables or we have the
very accurate very precision delivery
micro delivery of anesthesia to a mouse
with the saamne suite system the
typically would the saamne suite system
if i can just interject a small story
here I was at Vanderbilt last summer
visiting a laboratory and the user was
trying to use the pulse oximeter that
were are in that can be installed in
some suite to measure oxygen consumption
but he was also using a traditional
vaporizer and he couldn't understand why
his results were all over the place he
didn't have a saamne suite he only had
our the pulse oximeter in our Physiol to
go in and spend the morning with him and
we brought I brought us ominous suite
along and using his pulse oximeter plus
the pulse oximeter that was that's built
into the saamne suite as an optional
module
we were able to actually go in with us
ominous weeds and tight rates the depth
of anesthesia from one percent up to two
and a half percent and we were able to
reproducibly
during four cycles show him I was show
him that we can go from one extreme to
the other and predictably estimate the
heart rate and the respiration rate and
the spo2 values using room air and we
went from a very light breathing animal
to an animal that was at 1% to an animal
that was gasping and very hypoxic at two
and a half percent and we were able to
do that in between and and basically
adjust the animal within within 10
minutes up and down to show those
readings so precision in the delivery of
anesthesia is extremely important not
just the amount of anesthesia that's
going to the animal the amount that is
blasted but the percentage that the
animal is getting is extremely important
so that one of the ways of determining
the depth of anesthesia with the animal
you have the typical means of looking at
it which is the toe pinch righting
reflex when the animals be in the
induction chamber toe pinch as I said
what I like with mice is that when the
mice are getting light and when we're
working with them here we don't do any
invasive work but when we're testing
anesthesia or pulse oximeters or
something like that and we have the
animal sedated with the iso flooring
when the animals are getting very light
the first thing I like looking at is
that their tail starts curling up that
means they're starting to wake up so
then we know that we need to adjust the
anesthesia a little bit increasing
anesthesia a little bits of the ant so
the tail stays flaccid and at any point
in time here feel free to
any questions that you might have so
that we can get to those so with a pulse
oximeter as I was mentioning with the
with the incident at Vanderbilt last
summer with the researcher we're working
at we could actually titrate the level
using the pulse oximeter we could
titrate the respiration rates the heart
rates and the spo2 values just by
changing the level of anesthesia letting
the animal breathe room air and change
and monitoring those three parameters
the mouse pensar the mouse vent
automatic ventilator which I alluded to
before can be installed into the some
into the saamne suite system it is
always our recommendation that an animal
be ventilated because when you're using
100% oxygen on an animal that's
spontaneously breathing for the animal
to be deep enough having deep enough
anesthesia or to be induced deep enough
but their breathing is very compromised
you'll notice that when the animal is
two or two and a half percent ISO flora
and the animal is just gasping just
trying to stay alive so what we do in
research is to give the animal 100%
oxygen typically or something a very
high level of oxygen to compensate for
the gasping of the breathing but
breathing 100% oxygen is not a
physiological state that a normal animal
would be in so when you ventilate an
animal instead you have complete control
over the over the physiological
parameters of the animal and you can
increase and decrease their minute
volume you can increase by that's done
by increasing and decreasing the depth
of breathing by controlling the pressure
or tidal volume you can also increase
and decrease the
amount of the ventilation rate so both
of those will increase and decrease the
minute volume and the the the animal can
be breathing room air and be breathing
be under a more physiological condition
and you can adjust you can monitor the
ventilation either through the pulse
oximeter or by using a very accurate and
tidal co2 monitor to determine the
actual breathing or the physiological
state of the animal so just by
increasing the respiration rate which
increases the minute volume you can
watch the end tidal co2 values decrease
if you increase if or if you increase
the tidal volume of the animal you can
also see the co2 decrease and you can
also bring the animal almost titrate any
level of blood co2 that you are entitled
co2 that you would desire just by simply
changing respiration rate or or tidal
volume so that brings us to the end of
our brief presentation we hopefully
trying to show you that accuracy in
anesthesia is tremendously important and
that the parameter is that the also
monitoring all the variables that you
can so that you can reproduce the
experimental results are important so we
have a question from Russell Higby from
Santa Fe past door and he says
it's down here okay as the Heather
saamne sweet design concept been used
for larger ventilated or non-ventilated
laboratory animals they are constrict
are there constraints that prevent this
from occurring
the somnus week right now has been used
up to about 1 kilogram rats there's that
typically works just fine when we go to
a kill up to like a 500 or a kilogram
animal we typically put a 10 ml syringe
in the saamne suite that's not somnus we
can take a 2 5 or 10 ml syringe and at
the end of it the saamana suite is
designed to start beeping at the user
and automatically retreats so that the
you the user can drop another syringe
essentially another syringe cartridge
buts a gas a gas tight syringe that's
prefilled into the spot and press run
again and the soundless wheat will keep
going so that's maybe a 10 or 15 seconds
delay so larger and using the internal
pump we can deliver 500 milliliters and
minutes and using compress the carrier
gas it goes up to 800 milliliters a
minute which is typically fine for any
small laboratory animal we have another
question from Brenda a clown burg from
the National Institutes of Health Mouse
imaging facility she asks how well does
your anesthesia system work for long
lengths such such as an MRI image or
it's the people have been using it with
MRIs have had haven't had any problems
and we do have a actually an adaptor
which which can go with the saman suite
which delivers the anesthesia to a
vaporizer that's right at the animals
nose inside of the chamber if we don't
want to use the long runs of to
that way and and that's what we have for
questions well we can I thank you for
attending and hopefully you found this
to be somewhat instructive and have a
good day